- 양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강좌에
다시 오신 걸 환영해요.
저는 John Watrous이고, IBM Quantum에서
교육 기술 이사를 맡고 있어요.
이 강좌의 두 번째 수업이에요. 아직 첫 번째 수업을
보지 않으셨다면 꼭 확인해 보세요.
이번 수업은 첫 번째 수업에서 다뤘던 내용을
직접적으로 이어가기 때문에, 그 내용을
미리 이해해 두는 게 중요해요.
또한, 이 강좌에는 영상 외에도
교재 내용이 포함되어 있고, 교재 내용으로 가는 링크는
영상 설명란에서 찾을 수 있어요. 이번 수업은
강좌 1단원의 두 번째 수업이에요.
1단원에서는 양자 정보의
기초를 다뤄요.
이전 수업에서는 단일 시스템 환경에서의 양자 정보를 다뤘어요.
즉, 정보를 저장하는 시스템이 하나인 경우로,
그 시스템이 독립적으로
어떻게 작동하는지 설명했어요.
고전 정보에도 꽤 많은 시간을 할애했는데,
주로 기준점을 세우고 수학적 유사성을 강조하기 위해서였어요.
양자 정보와 고전 정보 사이의
수학적 유사성 말이에요.
또한 양자 상태가 벡터로 어떻게 표현되는지도 살펴봤어요.
구체적으로는 복소수 원소를 가지고
유클리드 노름이 1인 벡터로요.
그리고 표준 기저 측정과
유니터리 연산도 다뤘어요.
이번 수업에서는 시야를 넓혀서
여러 시스템을 다룰 거예요. 각 시스템은
양자 정보를 저장할 수 있어요.
이건 단순히 각 개별 시스템이
지난 시간에 설명한 대로 작동한다는 말이 아니에요.
어떤 의미에서 전체는
부분의 합보다 크고, 이는 확률이 관여할 때
고전 정보에서도 마찬가지예요.
여러 시스템은 서로 상호작용할 수 있고,
예를 들어 서로 상관관계를 가질 수도 있어요.
양자 환경에서는 그 가능성에
얽힘(entanglement)이 포함되는데,
이 용어는 전에 들어보셨을 수도 있어요.
얽힘은 양자 정보에서 매우 중요한 현상이고,
강좌가 계속되면서 훨씬 더 많이 다룰 거예요.
하지만 여러 시스템의 양자 정보를 생각하고
이해하는 데 꽤 유용한 간단한 원칙이 있어요.
그것은 우리가 언제든 두 개 이상의 시스템을
합치거나, 개념적으로 함께 생각할 수 있다는 거예요.
그리고 그것들이 하나의
복합 시스템을 이루는 것처럼 볼 수 있어요.
이렇게 복합 시스템을 단일 시스템인 것처럼 생각할 때,
우리가 배운 모든 것과 일관된 방식으로
설명되어야 한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
이전 수업의 단일 시스템 내용과 말이에요.
이게 어떻게 작동하는지, 그리고 여러 시스템의
양자 정보 설명이 단일 시스템의 작동 방식에서
꽤 자연스럽게 어떻게 도출되는지 살펴볼 거예요.
이 하나의 원칙을 기반으로요. 이번 수업의 개요가 있는데,
마침 이전 수업의 개요와 동일해요.
하지만 이번에는 단일 시스템이 아닌
여러 시스템에 집중할 거예요.
이전 수업과 마찬가지로, 똑같은 이유로
고전 정보부터 시작할 거예요.
다시 한번, 양자 정보와 고전 정보가
수학적 수준에서 얼마나 비슷하게 작동하는지
밀접한 유사성을 보게 될 거예요.
일반적으로 고전 정보에 이렇게 많이
집중하거나 강좌의 각 수업을 고전 정보로 시작하지는 않을 거예요.
이후 수업들은 양자 정보와 계산에
훨씬 더 집중적으로 초점을 맞출 거예요.
하지만 초반부에서는 이게 합리적인 접근이고,
고전 정보를 생각하는 것이라는 아이디어로 돌아가요.
고전 정보는 양자 정보를 이해하는 데
귀중한 안내 역할을 할 수 있어요.
또한 이번 수업 파트에서
텐서 곱이라는 중요한 개념도 다룰 거예요.
텐서 곱은 양자 정보에서 매우 중요하지만,
고전적인 환경에서도 등장해요.
그런 다음 양자 정보로 넘어가서, 이전 수업과 마찬가지로
양자 상태, 표준 기저 측정을 다룰 거예요.
그리고 이번에는 여러 시스템에 대한
유니터리 연산도요.
여러 시스템의 고전적
상태에 대해 먼저 이야기할게요.
이전 수업을 떠올려보면, 시스템의 고전적 상태란
불확실성이나 오류 없이 명확하게 인식되고
설명될 수 있는 시스템의 구성이에요.
수학적으로 고전적 상태 집합을 말할 때는,
단순히 유한하고 비어 있지 않은 집합을 의미해요.
유한하고 비어 있지 않은 집합이요.
두 시스템 X와 Y가 있다고 가정하면서
여러 시스템에 대한 설명을 시작할게요.
X는 고전적 상태의 집합을 가지는데, 이전 수업처럼
sigma라고 부를 거예요. Y는 고전적 상태의 집합을 가지는데,
gamma라고 부를 거예요. sigma와 gamma는
같은 집합일 수도 있고 다를 수도 있어요.
다른 이름을 붙이는 건 다른 집합일 수 있기 때문만이 아니라,
다른 이름을 사용하면 내용을 명확하게
유지하는 데 도움이 되기 때문이에요.
두 시스템에서 임의의 수의 시스템으로
이 전체 논의를 일반화하는 게 꽤 쉽다는 걸 알게 될 거예요.
하지만 두 시스템부터 시작하면,
세부 사항에 얽매이지 않고
핵심 아이디어에 집중할 수 있어요.
이제, X를 왼쪽에, Y를 오른쪽에 나란히 놓고
이 두 시스템을 함께 보는 걸 상상해 보세요.
마치 하나의 복합 시스템을 이루는 것처럼요.
이 새로운 시스템에 이름을 붙이려면,
이렇게 순서쌍으로 쓸 수도 있고,
그냥 두 글자를 이렇게 붙여 쓸 수도 있어요.
둘 다 흔히 쓰이고, 원하는 것이나
더 편한 것을 선택할 수 있어요.
어느 쪽이든 XY라고 읽어요.
이 시점에서 아주 자연스럽게 드는 질문은
이 새로운 복합 시스템 XY의 고전적 상태는
무엇인가 하는 거예요.
그 질문의 답은, XY의 고전적 상태 집합이
두 고전적 상태 집합의 데카르트 곱이라는 거예요.
sigma와 gamma의 곱인데,
여기서 정의된 걸 볼 수 있어요.
주어진 순간에 X는 sigma의 원소인 고전적 상태를 가지고,
Y는 gamma의 원소인 고전적 상태를 가져요.
그리고 우리는 단순히 이 두 상태를 함께
하나의 상태를 이루는 것처럼 생각하는데,
그게 바로
데카르트 곱이 포착하는 개념이에요. 각 집합에서
원소를 하나씩, 총 두 개를 가지고
이 두 원소를 함께 생각하고 싶은 거예요.
마치 하나의 집합에서 온
하나의 원소인 것처럼요.
명확히 하자면, 여기서 어떤 시스템이 X이고
어떤 시스템이 Y인지 알고 있다는 가정이 있어요.
그리고 둘 사이에 혼동이 없어야 해요. X가 물리적으로
왼쪽에 있고 Y가 오른쪽에 있는 게 중요한 게 아니에요.
두 시스템이 구별 가능하고,
어느 것이 어느 것인지 명확히 하기 위해
이런 순서로 정했다는 게 중요해요.
아주 간단한 예로, sigma가 이진 알파벳이고
gamma가 네 가지 카드 문양을 담은 집합인 경우예요.
X가 이진 값을 저장하고 Y가 네 가지 카드 문양 중 하나를
저장한다면, 여덟 가지 가능한 고전적 상태가 있어요.
XY 쌍의 상태들인데,
여기 나열된 걸 볼 수 있어요.
두 개 이상의 시스템에 대해서는
이게 간단한 방식으로 일반화돼요.
특히 X1부터 Xn까지의 시스템들이
각각 고전적 상태 집합 sigma 1부터 sigma n을 가진다면,
n개의 시스템을 묶어서 하나의 시스템으로 보면,
고전적 상태 집합은 데카르트 곱으로 주어져요.
n개의 고전적 상태 집합
sigma 1부터 sigma n의 데카르트 곱이요.
화면에서 볼 수 있듯이요. 데카르트 곱은
임의의 수의 집합에 대해 이렇게 정의될 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 세 개의 시스템이 있고 모두 고전적 상태
집합으로 이진 알파벳을 공유한다면,
즉 세 개의 비트가 있다면,
세 비트를 하나의 시스템으로 볼 때
여덟 가지 가능한 고전적 상태가 있고,
여기 나열된 걸 볼 수 있어요.
각 시스템은 개별적으로 0 또는 1 상태를 가질 수 있고,
가능한 모든 조합을 나열해요.
고전적 상태의 n-튜플은 괄호와 쉼표를 빼고
여기서 보이는 것처럼 문자열로 쓸 수도 있어요.
이진 알파벳의 매우 흔한 예처럼 고전적 상태를
기호로 생각할 때 특히 합리적이에요.
계속 돌아오게 되는 예시예요. 이렇게 하면
매우 편리할 때가 많고, 수식을 더 간단하게
깔끔하게 만드는 경향이 있어요. 문자열의 개념은
실제로 데카르트 곱을 통해 수학적으로 형식화돼요.
따라서 이건 개념적으로 다른 것이 아니라
단순히 대안적인 표기법이에요.
예로, X1부터 X10까지
10개의 비트가 있다고 해봐요.
그러면 10개의 비트를 합친 고전적 상태 집합은,
예를 들어 컴퓨터의 10비트 레지스터로 자연스럽게
생각할 수 있는 것인데,
이진 알파벳 자신과의
10배 데카르트 곱이에요.
그 상태들을 문자열로 쓰면 여기서 보이는 것처럼
보이고, 1,024개가 있어요.
물론 여기에 전부 나열되진 않았어요. 여기 세 개의 점은
추론할 수 있는 패턴이 있다는 걸 나타내요.
이해하셨으면 좋겠어요. 이제 데카르트 곱
집합의 원소 순서에 관한 규칙이 있어요.
확률적 상태와 양자 상태를 벡터로 표현하기 위해
이걸 명확히 하는 게 중요해요.
규칙은 데카르트 곱 집합의 원소를
사전순으로 정렬하는 거예요.
기본적으로 사전 순서를 의미해요.
더 구체적으로, 데카르트 곱을 취하는 각 개별 집합이
이미 자체적인 순서를 가지고 있다는 가정에서 시작해요.
그리고 주어진 n-튜플이나 문자열을
단어처럼 생각해서 알파벳 순으로 정렬해요.
다르게 말하면, n-튜플이나 문자열 내의 위치가
왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 중요도가 감소해요.
0부터 9까지의 숫자로 숫자를 쓸 때처럼요.
이를 명확히 하기 위한
예가 있어요.
1, 2, 3을 담은 집합과 이진 알파벳의 데카르트 곱을 취하면,
여섯 개의 원소를 담은 집합이 나와요.
여기 설명된 순서로
나열되어 있어요.
첫 번째 위치에 1이 있는 원소들이
첫 번째 위치에 2가 있는 원소들보다 앞에 오고,
그것들은 모든 원소들보다 앞에 와요.
첫 번째 위치에 3이 있는 원소들보다 앞에 와요.
그리고 두 원소의 첫 번째 위치가 같으면,
두 번째 위치의 순서를 따라요.
그게 데카르트 곱에
사용하는 순서예요.
이 규칙을 사용해서 n-튜플을 문자열로 쓰면
매우 친숙한 패턴들이 나타나요.
예를 들어, 이진 알파벳 자신과의 데카르트 곱은
여기서 보이는 것처럼 정렬돼요.
이 문자열들을 음이 아닌 정수의 이진 인코딩으로 보면
수치적으로 정렬된 것처럼 생각할 수 있고, 이는
임의의 문자열 길이로 일반화돼요. 확률적 상태로 넘어가면,
이전 수업에서 이미 알고 있듯이
확률적 상태는 주어진 시스템의
각 고전적 상태에 확률을 연결해요.
두 개 이상의 시스템을 합쳐서 방금 논의한 것처럼
하나의 시스템인 것처럼 보는 복합 시스템이 있다면,
이 복합 시스템의 확률적 상태는
개별 시스템들의 데카르트 곱의 원소에
확률을 할당해야 해요.
고전적 상태 집합들의요. 그게 복합 시스템의
고전적 상태 집합이기 때문이에요.
예를 들어, X와 Y가 비트라고 하면,
XY의 확률적 상태의 예가 있어요.
두 비트 모두 0일 확률은 1/2이고
두 비트 모두 1일 확률도 1/2이에요.
즉, 두 비트는 절대 서로 다른 값을 가지지 않아요.
이건 XY의 유효한 확률적 상태이고,
벡터로 대신 쓸 수 있어요.
여기서 보이는 것처럼요. 고전적 상태를 정렬하기 위해
아까 설명한 규칙을 따르고 있는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이건 X와 Y가 상관관계를 가지는
확률적 상태의 예이고, 전체가
부분의 합보다 크다는 의미예요. 앞서 말했듯이,
단순히 X의 확률적 상태와
Y의 확률적 상태를 합치는 게 아니라,
먼저 시스템들을 합치고
그런 다음 복합 시스템의
확률적 상태를 생각하는 거예요.
시스템들 사이의 상관관계를 더 정확히 이해하려면,
독립성의 개념을 먼저 정의해야 해요.
독립성은 본질적으로 상관관계가 없는 것이에요.
여기서 독립성이라는 용어는
벡터의 선형 독립성과 달리
통계적 독립성을 의미해요.
이건 확률과 통계에서
기본적인 개념이에요.
두 시스템 X와 Y가 있고 XY의 어떤 확률적 상태가
있다면, X와 Y가 독립적이라고 해요.
여기서 보이는 공식이 X와 Y의
모든 고전적 상태 a와 b에 대해 참일 때요.
이 독립성 조건을 해석하는 한 가지 방법은,
X가 어떤 하나의 고전적 상태에 있을 확률과
Y가 다른 어떤 고전적 상태에 있을 확률이
서로 전혀 관계없다는 것을 의미해요.
따라서 한 시스템의 상태를 알아도
다른 시스템의 상태와 관련된 확률에
영향을 주지 않아요.
어떤 절차에 따라 X의 고전적 상태를 무작위로 선택하고,
그런 다음 Y의 고전적 상태를 무작위로 선택한다고 상상해 보세요.
X와 전혀 연결되지 않은 다른 절차에 따라요.
예를 들어 한 사람이 동전을 던지고
다른 방에 있는 다른 사람이 주사위를 굴리는 경우라면,
이게 바로 다양한 조합의 확률을 구하는 데
사용하는 공식이에요.
상태 조합이 나타날 확률이요. 이 정의의 요점은
공식이 유효할 때 독립성이라는 거예요.
확률 벡터 측면에서 확률적 상태를 생각하면,
이 조건에 대한 간단한 공식화가 있어요.
구체적으로, XY의 확률적 상태가 있는데
이를 직접 표기법으로 벡터로 표현할 수 있어요.
여기서 보이는 것처럼요. 그러면 X와 Y가 독립적이라는 것은
두 개의 확률 벡터가 존재하는 것과 동치예요.
|Phi>와 |Psi>인데, 간단히 Phi와 Psi라고 읽을 수 있어요.
이것들은 각각
X와 Y의 확률적 상태를 나타내는데,
여기서 보이는 등식을 만족해요.
모든 a와 b 선택에 대해서요. 본질적으로
정의를 벡터 측면에서 다시 표현한 거예요.
예를 들어, X와 Y가 독립적인
비트 쌍 XY의 확률적 상태가 있어요.
독립성에 필요한 조건은
여기서 보이는 벡터에 대해 참이에요.
즉, 두 비트의 각 가능한 설정에 대한 확률은
개별 비트의 해당 확률들의 곱으로 주어져요.
예를 들어, 두 비트가 모두 0을 취할 확률은 1/6이고,
이는 1/4 곱하기 2/3와 같아요.
나머지 세 가지 경우에 대해서도 마찬가지이고,
하나씩 확인할 수 있어요.
반면에 앞서 본 확률적 상태, 즉 항상 같은 값을 취하면서
각각 1/2의 확률로 0과 1을 취하는 두 비트의 경우에는
독립성이 없고, 그래서
비트들이 상관관계를 가진다고 해요.
상관관계는 단순히
독립성의 결여를 의미해요.
두 비트가 독립적이지 않다는 걸 증명하는 간단한 방법은
독립적이라고 가정하고 모순을 도출하는 거예요.
구체적으로, 두 비트가 독립적이라면
q0, q1, r0, r1이라는 숫자들이 존재해야 해요.
두 개별 비트의 확률을 나타내는 숫자들로,
여기 있는 방정식들이 만족되어야 해요.
이것들은 우리 벡터에서 나온 확률이고,
독립성 조건에 의해 참이어야 하는
방정식들이에요.
하지만 여기 두 번째 등식을 보면,
q0 곱하기 r1이 0과 같아야 한다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
두 실수의 곱이 0이 되는 유일한 방법은
적어도 그 수 중 하나 자체가 0인 경우예요.
이것을 실수의 영의 곱 성질이라고
부르기도 해요.
다른 말로 하면, 두 0이 아닌 실수의
곱은 항상 0이 아니에요.
따라서 이 등식은 q0이 0이거나
r1이 0임을 의미해요.
하지만 첫 번째와 마지막 등식에서 그 두 가지 선택지 중
어느 것도 참일 수 없다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
q0이 0이면 이 곱은 0이어야 하지만 0이 아니에요.
r1이 0이면
이 곱은 0이어야 하지만 그것도 참이 아니에요.
따라서 모순이 생기고, X와 Y가 독립적이지 않아서
상관관계를 가진다는 결론을 내려요.
방금 논의한 독립성의 개념, 특히 확률 벡터 측면에서의
공식화는 밀접하게 연결되어 있어요.
텐서 곱이라고 알려진 벡터에 대한
연산과요.
텐서 곱은 벡터뿐만 아니라
행렬에 대해서도 정의될 수 있어요.
실제로 텐서 곱의 개념은 정의될 수 있어요.
다른 많은 종류의
수학적 대상에 대해서도요.
순수 수학에서 중요하고 유용한 꽤 추상적인 방식으로
설명할 수 있지만, 벡터에 대한 텐서 곱도 정의할 수 있어요.
매우 간단하고 구체적인 방식으로요. 그게 이번 수업에서
취할 방법이에요.
여기서 보이는 형태로 쓴 두 열 벡터 Phi와 Psi가 있으면,
sigma와 gamma는 임의의 고전적 상태 집합이거나
원하면 인덱스예요. 그러면 이 벡터들의 텐서 곱이
여기서 보이는 벡터예요.
두 집합 sigma와 gamma의 데카르트 곱의
모든 원소를 나열하고, 이 벡터에서
각 쌍 ab에 해당하는 원소는, 여기서 문자열로 쓰인 것처럼,
해당하는 원소들의 곱과 같아요.
두 벡터의 원소들의 곱이요. 다시 말해, Phi 텐서 Psi의 ab 원소는
Phi의 a 원소와 Psi의 b 원소의 곱이에요.
그게 여기 쓰인 것의
의미예요.
본질적으로, 이건 독립성을 논의할 때
방금 본 연산과 같아요.
지금은 단순히 이름을 붙이는 거예요.
방금 본 것과 완전히 같은 예를
텐서 곱 측면에서 더 명시적으로 쓴 거예요.
다시, 1/6은 1/4 곱하기 1/3과 같고,
1/12는 1/4 곱하기 1/3과 같은 식이에요.
그런데 여기 두 벡터의 텐서 곱을
쓰는 몇 가지 대안적인 방법이 있어요.
직접 표기법을 사용할 때 두 켓을 이렇게 나란히 쓰면,
텐서 곱을 의미해요.
따라서 텐서 곱을 두 열 벡터를 곱하는
기본 방법으로 생각할 수 있어요.
차원이 맞지 않기 때문에 행렬 곱셈 측면에서
이런 식으로 열 벡터의 곱을 생각하는 건 말이 안 돼요.
그래서 모호함에 대한
걱정은 없어요.
텐서 곱을 켓 안에 이렇게 쓸 수도 있고,
정확히 같은 의미예요.
두 벡터의
텐서 곱이요.
첫 번째 방법이 매우 일반적이고, 실제로 텐서 곱 기호 없이
이렇게 텐서 곱을 쓰는 게 더 일반적이에요.
기호를 포함하는 것보다요. 두 번째 방법은 훨씬 덜 일반적이지만,
주로 특정 상황에서
추가 괄호의 필요성을 없애는 방법으로
때때로 매우 도움이 돼요.
여기서 볼 수 있듯이, 실제 숫자 열의 관점에서
텐서 곱을 명시적으로 표현할 수도 있어요.
여기 두 열 벡터의 텐서 곱을 취하면,
얻는 벡터가 이거예요.
그리고 여기 원소들이 이 두 벡터에서 오는
원소들의 곱인 걸 볼 수 있어요.
텐서 곱의 원소 순서는 방금 전의 정의와 일관적이에요.
데카르트 곱 집합의 원소를 정렬하기 위해
앞서 설명한 규칙을 따르면 돼요.
그 규칙을 따르는 것은 첫 번째 벡터의 인덱스가
두 번째 벡터의 인덱스보다 더 높은 중요도를 가진다고
생각하는 것과 동치예요.
따라서 텐서 곱의 원소를 나열할 때,
왼쪽 첫 번째 벡터의 첫 번째 원소를 포함하는
모든 곱이 있어요.
그게 alpha 1이에요. 그런 다음 왼쪽 벡터의 두 번째 원소를
포함하는 모든 곱이 있고, 그게 alpha 2예요. 이런 식으로 계속돼요.
왼쪽 벡터에 세 개의 원소가 있고
오른쪽 벡터에 네 개의 원소가 있는 예가 있어요.
무슨 일이 일어나는지 더 명확히 볼 수 있어요.
첫 번째 벡터에 세 개의 원소가 있으므로,
두 번째 벡터의 복사본 세 개를 쓰고,
그 각 복사본에 해당하는 원소를 곱해요.
첫 번째 벡터의 해당 원소를
이렇게요.
alpha를 이렇게 안으로 가져오고,
여기서 그냥 벡터에 스칼라를 곱하는 거예요.
마지막으로 복사본에서 괄호를 제거하고
여기서 보이는 것처럼 하나의 열 벡터를 만들어요.
중요한 점으로, 표준 기저 벡터의 텐서 곱에
다음과 같은 공식이 있다는 걸 알아두세요.
|a>와 |b>의 텐서 곱을 취하면,
여기서 보이는 것처럼 텐서 곱 기호를 사용하거나 없이 쓸 수 있어요.
그 결과는 단순히 |ab>예요.
ab를 문자열 대신 순서쌍으로 쓰고 싶으면
그렇게 할 수 있고, 여기 이 식을 얻어요.
하지만 훨씬 더 흔한 건
괄호를 빼지만 쉼표는 남기는 이것이에요.
어떤 의미에서 괄호가 있는 이게 더 정확할 수 있지만,
수학에서는 꽤 표준적인 규칙이에요.
필요하거나 도움이 되지 않을 때
괄호를 제거하는 거요.
여기 이것에서 괄호가 암묵적으로 있다고 생각할 수 있고,
더 깔끔하고 보기 좋아요.
텐서 곱에는 중요한 성질이 있는데,
그게 이중선형이에요. 즉, 선형이에요.
나머지 하나가 고정되었을 때
두 인수 각각에 대해서요.
좀 더 자세히 말하면,
여기서 보이는 두 방정식으로 표현되는 첫 번째 인수에 대해 선형이에요.
첫 번째는 두 벡터 Phi1과 Phi2를 더하고 Psi와의 텐서 곱을 취하면,
텐서 곱을 먼저 취한 결과를 더하는 것과 같다고 해요.
Psi와 먼저 취하고 나서 더하는 것과요.
두 번째는 어떤 벡터 Phi에 스칼라 alpha를 곱하고
Psi와의 텐서 곱을 취하면,
Phi와 Psi의 텐서 곱을 먼저 취하고 결과에 alpha를 곱하는 것과
같다고 해요.
두 번째 인수에 대해서도 선형성이 있는데,
두 인수의 역할이 바뀐다는 것만 빼면 같아요.
이중선형성은 정의에서 확인하기 꽤 간단하지만,
이 공식들을 자주 사용할 것이기 때문에
이렇게 써두는 게 좋아요.
그런데 스칼라는 여기서 보이는 등식의 의미에서
텐서 곱을 통해 자유롭게 이동한다는 걸 알아두세요.
즉, 이 경우 첫 번째 인수에 스칼라 alpha를 곱하는 것과
두 번째 인수에 그 스칼라를 곱하는 것 사이에 차이가 없어요.
아니면 전체에 그 스칼라를
곱하는 것 사이에도요.
이 등식들은 여기 두 방정식에서 나오고,
이 벡터들 사이에 차이가 없기 때문에,
여기서 보이는 것처럼 식을 쓸 수 있어요.
괄호 없이요. 필요가 없기 때문이에요.
명확성을 더하거나 모호함을 제거하지 않으므로,
그냥 제거하면 더 깔끔한 식을 얻어요.
이 모든 것은 세 개 이상의 시스템으로
일반화돼요.
두 벡터의 텐서 곱에 대한 공식을 자연스러운 방식으로 일반화해서
세 개 이상 벡터의 텐서 곱을 정의할 수 있어요.
여기서 표현된 것처럼요. 텐서 곱의 각 원소는
해당하는 원소들의 곱으로 주어져요.
텐서 곱을 취하는
벡터들의 해당 원소들의요.
세 개 이상 벡터의 텐서 곱을 정의하는
동치의 방법은 재귀적으로 하는 거예요.
결국 정의로 돌아가서
두 벡터 사이의 텐서 곱으로요. n이 최소 3이면,
n개의 벡터의 텐서 곱을 생각할 수 있어요.
Phi1부터 Phi n까지, 처음 n-1개의 텐서 곱을 취해서
얻는 벡터와 마지막 벡터 사이의 텐서 곱으로요.
처음 n-1개 벡터의 텐서 곱이 무엇인지 알고 싶으면,
n-1이 최소 3인 경우 공식을 다시 적용하거나
n-1이 2이면 이전의 정의를 사용해요.
세 개 이상 벡터의 텐서 곱에 대한
두 가지 사고 방식은 동치예요.
이번에 세 개 이상의 벡터의 텐서 곱을 취할 때는
이중선형이라는 용어를 사용하지 않아요.
대신 다중선형이라는 용어를 사용하지만,
아이디어는 같아요.
텐서 곱은 다른 모든 위치의 벡터들이 고정되었을 때
각 위치에서 선형이에요.
고정된 경우요. 확률적 상태에서 여러 시스템의
측정으로 넘어가면,
모든 시스템이 측정될 경우에, 단순히 여러 시스템을
단일 시스템으로 집합적으로 생각해서
측정이 작동하는 방식에 대한 사양을 즉시 얻어요.
모든 시스템이
측정되는 경우요.
간단한 예로, 두 비트 X와 Y가 있고
집합적으로 여기 있는 이 확률적 상태에 있다고 가정해 봐요.
전에 본 것이에요. 당연히, 이 두 비트를 모두 측정하면
결과 00을 얻을 거예요.
첫 번째 측정에서 0, 두 번째 측정에서 0이
1/2의 확률로 나오고, 결과 1,1을 얻을 거예요.
마찬가지로 1/2의 확률로요. 꽤 간단해요.
본질적으로, 모든 시스템을 측정하는 것은
전체 복합 시스템을 측정하는 것과 동치예요.
하지만 모든 시스템을 측정하지 않고
일부 시스템만 측정한다면, 상황이
그렇게 즉시 명확하지 않아요.
가능한 한 간단한 환경에서 핵심을 이해하기 위해
두 시스템의 경우로만 다시 제한해서요.
다음 질문을 할 수 있어요. 두 시스템 X와 Y가 함께
쌍으로 있다고 가정해 봐요.
어떤 특정 확률적 상태에
있는 경우요.
X만 측정하고 Y는
아무것도 하지 않으면 어떻게 될까요?
이 질문은 기본적인 확률 이론을 사용해서
답할 수 있어요.
먼저, 측정이 특정 결과를 줄 확률은
여기서 보이는 이 공식으로 주어져야 한다는 걸 알아요.
두 비트를 모두 측정한 것처럼 쌍 XY의 각 고전적 상태에 대한
확률을 생각할 수 있고, 관심 있는 고전적 상태 a에
X가 있는 것과 일치하는 모든 확률을 합해요.
X가 관심 있는 고전적 상태 a에 있는 것과
일치하는 모든 확률들을요.
그래서 여기서 합이 Y의 고전적 상태 b에 대해서만
이루어지는 거예요.
이 공식을 생각하는 한 가지 방법은, X를 측정할 때
특정 고전적 상태를 볼 확률은
Y도 측정했을 때 그 상태를 볼 확률과 일치해야 한다는 거예요.
실제로 측정하지 않더라도요.
매우 자연스럽고 직관적이에요. X 측정이 특정 결과를 낼 확률은
결과에 관계없이 Y도
측정되었는지 여부에 따라
달라질 수 있어요.
그것이 측정의 다양한 가능한 결과에 대한 확률이
무엇인지 알려주는데, Y나 우리의 Y에 대한 지식은
그 결과로 어떻게 될까요?
답은 X를 측정한 결과로
Y의 상태에 대한 불확실성이
여전히 존재할 수 있다는 거예요.
그리고 특정 결과를 보고 나서요. 그 불확실성은 조건부 확률에 대한
여기 이 공식으로 표현돼요.
Y가 어떤 특정 고전적 상태 b에 있는,
X가 어떤 고전적 상태에 있다는 조건 하에서의 확률이요.
우리가 측정한 고전적 상태 a,
무엇이든요.
정확히 말하면, X가 고전적 상태 a에 있다는 조건 하에서
Y가 고전적 상태 b에 있을 확률은
X가 a에 있고 Y가 b에 있을 확률을
X가
고전적 상태 a에 있을 확률로 나눈 것과 같아요.
X를 측정하면, 여기 이 공식으로 결정된 확률로
다양한 고전적 상태를 보게 될 거예요.
그리고 어떤 결과를 얻느냐에 따라, Y의 고전적 상태에 대한
불확실성이 여전히 있을 수 있고,
그 불확실성은 반영돼요.
여기 이 공식으로요.
실제로 이 모든 것을 다시 표현하고
직접 표기법을 사용해서 특정 경우에 대한 계산을 수행하는
매우 쉬운 방법이 있어요.
XY의 확률적 상태를 이런 벡터로 쓰는 것에서 시작해요.
이건 완전히 일반적이에요.
원소들은 Pab로 표시되고, 전체 벡터가
확률 벡터인 한 어떤 숫자도 될 수 있어요.
|ab>를 여기서 보이는 것처럼 텐서 곱으로 표현하고,
텐서 곱의 이중선형성을 사용할 수 있어요.
구체적으로 두 번째 인수에 대한 선형성을 이용해서
여기서 보이는 것처럼 이 벡터를 표현해요.
우리가 하는 건 효과적으로 왼쪽에 표준 기저 벡터를
분리하고 오른쪽에 필요한 것을 놓는 거예요.
그게 가능하게 하기 위해서요. 그것이 첫 번째 시스템 X를
측정할 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지를 드러낼 거예요.
구체적으로, 특정 결과 a를 얻을 확률은
|a> 옆의 괄호 안에 있는 모든 확률의 합이에요.
그리고 특정 결과 a를 얻는 것에 조건부로,
Y에 대해 남아 있는 불확실성을 설명하는 확률 벡터는
a 옆의 괄호 안에 있던
벡터예요.
단, 확률 벡터로 만들기 위해 정규화해야 해요.
즉, 그 벡터를
확률 벡터를 형성하기 위해 그 벡터의 원소들의 합으로 나눠야 해요.
그런데 여기서 합은 b가 아닌 gamma의 모든 c에 대해 취해요.
혼동이 없도록 다른 변수 이름을 사용하기 위해서예요.
변수의 범위에 대해
혼동이 없도록요.
분자와 분모의 합은 별개로 생각해야 해요.
그에 대한 혼동 가능성을 피하기 위해
두 합에 대해 다른 변수를
사용하면 돼요.
이 모든 것이 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하는
간단한 예가 있어요.
XY가 여기 이 확률적 상태에 있는 한 쌍의 비트라고 가정해요.
첫 번째 비트를 측정할 때 어떻게 되는지 이해하기 위해
두 번째에는 아무것도 하지 않으면서요. 첫 번째 위치에서
|0>과 |1>이 분리되도록 벡터를 써요.
방금 설명한 것처럼
분리되도록요.
첫 번째 가능성은 측정 결과가 0이고,
그 확률은 괄호 안의 확률들의 합이에요.
|0>에 텐서 곱된 것들이에요. 그래서 1/12 + 1/4 = 1/3을 얻고,
결과 0에 조건부로요.
Y의 확률적 상태는 이 벡터를 정규화하거나, 동치로
우리가 방금 계산한 확률로 나눈 것이 돼요.
그래서 얻는 것은
여기 이 벡터예요.
두 번째 가능성은 측정 결과가 1인 경우이고,
식의 첫 번째 항 대신 두 번째 항을 사용해서
비슷한 방식으로 계산해요.
세부 사항을 확인하고 싶다면, 항상 그렇듯이 영상을 일시 정지하고
잠깐 확인해 보세요.
X 대신 Y를 측정할 때 어떻게 되는지
알아내기 위해 동일한 종류의 계산을 할 수 있어요.
두 시스템 사이의 대칭성에 따라
같은 방법이에요.
이번에는 확률 벡터를 이렇게 써요.
여기서 보이는 것처럼 오른쪽에 표준 기저 벡터를 분리해요.
하지만 그 외에는
정확히 같은 방식으로 작동해요.
두 개 이상의 시스템에도
이 방법을 사용할 수 있어요.
필요한 모든 식을 쓰는 게 좀 지저분해질 수 있지만,
개념적으로는 정확히 같은 아이디어예요.
마지막으로, 고전 정보에 관한 수업 부분에서
여러 시스템의 확률적 상태에 대한 연산을
살펴볼게요.
이제 몇 번 본 것과 같은 추론을 따라서요.
여러 시스템에 대한 확률적 연산은 단일 시스템에 대한
확률적 연산과 같고, 확률적 행렬로 표현된다는 결론을 내려요.
하지만 이번에 그 행렬들은
개별 시스템들의 고전적 상태 집합의
데카르트 곱에 해당하는 행과 열을 가져요.
즉, 단순히 복합 시스템을 단일 시스템인 것처럼 보고,
확률적 연산이 어떻게 작동하는지에 대한
설명으로 돌아가는 거예요.
이전 수업의 단일 시스템에 대한
설명으로요.
두 비트 X와 Y에 대한 controlled-NOT 연산이라는
연산의 예가 있어요.
이건 결정론적 연산이고, 작동 방식은
X가 1이면 Y에 NOT 연산이 수행되고,
그렇지 않고 X가 0이면
아무것도 일어나지 않아요.
비트 X는 때때로 제어 비트라고 불려요.
NOT 연산이 Y에 적용되는지 여부를 결정하기 때문이에요.
Y는 목표 비트라고 불려요.
NOT 연산이 작용하는 비트이기 때문이에요.
X와 Y의 역할을 바꿔서 Y가 제어 비트가 되고
X가 목표가 되는 것도 상상할 수 있지만, 그건 다른 연산이에요.
여기 설명된 것과는 다른 연산이에요.
X와 Y 사이에서 연산이 대칭적이지 않기 때문이에요.
둘 다 controlled-NOT 연산이라고 불리고,
어느 비트가 제어 비트이고
어느 것이 목표 비트인지만 지정하면 돼요.
이 연산은 표준 기저 상태에서 여기 보이는 작용을 가지고,
정의에 대해 그 작용을 확인할 수 있어요.
연산의 정의에 대해서요. 그리고 여기 연산의
행렬 표현이 있어요.
이 연산에 대해 생각할 때, 두 개의 별개 비트가 있고
방금 설명한 역할을 한다는 걸 생각해요.
X가 제어 비트이고
Y가 목표 비트예요. 하지만 이 작용이나 이 행렬 표현에는
정말로 아무것도 없어요.
이 두 비트를 별개의 비트로
생각하게 하는 것은요.
대신 이 연산을 네 개의 고전적 상태를 가진 시스템에 대한
결정론적 연산으로 생각할 수도 있어요.
이름을 0,0, 0,1, 1,0, 1,1로
붙이기로 한 시스템이요.
두 비트에 대한 확률적 연산의 또 다른 예가 있는데,
이번에는 결정론적 연산이 아니에요.
이 연산은 1/2의 확률로 Y를 X와 같게 설정하고,
그렇지 않으면 반대로 X를 Y와 같게 설정해요.
이 연산에는 특별한 이름이 없고
그냥 예시로만 쓰여요.
그리고 여기 이 연산의
행렬 표현이 있어요.
두 행렬의 평균으로 표현될 수 있다는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
하나는 결정론적 연산을 나타내는 행렬이고,
Y가 X에 저장된 값으로 설정되는 것과,
X가 Y와 같게 설정되는 다른 행렬이에요.
따라서 여기서 이전 수업에서와 마찬가지로
확률적 행렬의 평균을 취해서 새로운 것을 얻을 수 있다는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이제 다음 질문을 고려해 봐요. 각각 자신의 시스템에서
두 개의 확률적 연산이 있다고 가정해요.
일반적으로 확률적 행렬로 설명되는데,
정확하게는 M이 확률적 연산이라고 가정해요.
시스템 X에 대한 확률적 연산이고
N은 시스템 Y에 대한 확률적 연산이에요.
질문은 X에 M을 Y에 N을 동시에 수행하면,
이것이 복합 시스템 XY에 미치는 영향을
어떻게 설명하냐는 거예요.
복합 시스템 XY에 대한
영향을요.
잠시 직관적으로 생각해 보면, 각각의 시스템에서
두 연산을 동시에 수행하면,
실제로 복합 시스템에서 연산을 수행하는 것이므로,
어떤 확률적 행렬로 설명되어야 해요.
이 질문에 대한 짧은 답은 행렬이 텐서 곱을 취해서 얻어진다는 거예요.
앞서 이야기한 것처럼 벡터들 사이의 텐서 곱이 아니라요.
하지만 이 경우 행렬들 사이의 텐서 곱이에요.
행렬 M과 N이요.
잠시 행렬의 텐서 곱에 대해 논의하고
이 질문으로 돌아올게요.
여기 행렬 사이의 텐서 곱의 정의가 있는데,
벡터 사이의 텐서 곱과 매우 유사해요.
여기서 보이는 형태로 쓴 두 행렬로 작업하면,
M의 원소는 a와 b가
고전적 상태 집합 sigma를 나열하면서 alpha ab로 표시되고,
N의 원소는 c와 d가
고전적 상태 집합 gamma를 나열하면서
beta cd로 표시돼요.
그러면 M과 N의 곱은
여기서 보이는 행렬이에요.
벡터 사이의 텐서 곱과
비슷해요.
M 텐서 N의 행과 열은 고전적 상태 쌍에 해당하고,
여기서 문자열로 쓰여 있어요.
그리고 원소들은 M과 N의 해당 원소들의
곱이에요.
이 행렬들의 개별 원소 측면에서
쓰는 또 다른 방법이 있어요.
M 텐서 N의 ac bd 원소는 M의 ab 원소와
N의 cd 원소의 곱이에요.
M 텐서 N을 설명하는 또 다른 방법은,
Phi 텐서 Psi 형태의 임의의 벡터를
M을 Phi에 적용한 것과 N을 Psi에 적용한 것의 텐서 곱으로 변환하는
유일한 행렬이라는 거예요. 모든 선택에 대해 참이어야 해요.
벡터 Phi와 Psi의 모든 선택에 대해서요.
이것을 생각하는 한 가지 방법은 행렬의 텐서 곱이
벡터 사이의 텐서 곱과 완벽하게 잘 어울린다는 거예요.
이건 자연스럽게 참이기를 바라는 방정식이고,
실제로 그래요.
명시적으로 쓴 행렬 측면에서,
텐서 곱을 여기서 보이는 것처럼 정의할 수 있어요.
이 방정식에 점들이 많고, 패턴을 설명하기 위한 거예요.
벡터에 대한 것과 같은 패턴인데,
이제 행과 열이 있어요.
단지 열 벡터만이 아닌
행과 열이요.
명확하지 않은 경우,
다음 예가 도움이 될 거예요.
여기서 두 개의 2x2 행렬의
텐서 곱에 대해 이야기해요.
먼저 두 번째 행렬의 복사본 네 개를 써요.
첫 번째 행렬의 각 원소에 대해 하나씩이요.
두 번째 행렬의 각 복사본에 첫 번째 행렬의
해당 원소를 곱해요.
그런 다음 여기서 보이는 것처럼
하나의 4x4 행렬로 모아요.
세 개 이상 행렬의 텐서 곱도 유사한 방식으로 정의할 수 있고,
아마도 가장 쉬운 표현 방법은
여기서 보이는 것처럼이에요. 텐서 곱의 각 원소에 대한 공식이 있는데,
단순히 해당 원소들의 곱이에요.
벡터에 대해 했던 것처럼 단지 두 행렬의 텐서 곱 측면에서
재귀적으로 세 개 이상 행렬의 텐서 곱을 정의할 수도 있어요.
마지막으로 한 가지는, 행렬의 텐서 곱은
곱에 관해 성립해요. 즉, 텐서 곱의 곱은
곱들의 텐서 곱과
같다는 거예요.
이것을 행렬의 텐서 곱이 텐서 곱의 벡터에 작용하는
방금 전의 공식의 일반화로 생각할 수 있어요.
텐서 곱의 벡터에 대한 작용이요. 다시, 이게 참이기를 당연히 바라고,
그렇다는 걸 기뻐할 수 있어요.
그리고 필요할 때마다
이 사실을 사용할 거예요.
이제 이전의 질문으로 돌아갈 수 있어요. 시스템 X에서 연산 M을 수행하고
시스템 Y에서 연산 N을 수행하는 효과를
복합 시스템 XY에 대한 연산으로
어떻게 설명하는지 묻는 질문이에요.
그 질문에 대한 답은
그 작용이 M과 N의 텐서 곱으로 설명된다는 거예요.
텐서 곱은 이번에 연산들 사이의 독립성을 나타내요.
확률 벡터에 대해 앞서 본 것과 반대로요.
간단한 예가 있어요. 비트 X에 이 행렬로 설명된
확률적 연산을 수행한다고 가정해요.
이건 수업 1에서 본 연산이고,
동시에 비트 Y에 NOT 연산을 수행해요.
따라서 쌍 XY에 대한 결합 연산은 이 두 연산에 해당하는
행렬들의 텐서 곱으로 표현돼요.
X에 대한 것은 여기 있고, Y에 대한 NOT 연산은 여기 있어요.
그리고 여기서 보이는 이 행렬을 얻어요.
실제로 이게 확률적 행렬이라는 걸 볼 수 있고,
항상 그럴 거예요.
임의의 두 확률적 행렬 또는 임의의 수의 확률적 행렬의
텐서 곱은 항상 확률적일 거예요.
한 시스템에서 하나의 연산을 수행하고
다른 시스템에는 아무것도 하지 않는 상황을
매우 자주 접해요.
이 상황에서, 아무것도 하지 않는 것이
항등 행렬로 표현된다는 이해 하에 정확히 같은 방법을 따라요.
예를 들어, 두 비트 X와 Y가 있고
비트 X를 0 상태로 초기화하면,
이건 X에 상수 0 함수를 수행하는 것과 같고,
Y에는 아무것도 하지 않으면, XY 쌍에 대한 결과 연산은
여기 이 텐서 곱으로
표현돼요.
이 모든 것은 임의의 수의 시스템으로 일반화되고,
양자 환경으로 넘어갈 때 몇 가지 추가 예를 볼 거예요.
정확히 같은 방식으로 작동해요.
확률적 행렬 대신 유니터리 행렬을 가진다는 것만 빼고요.
이제 고전 정보에 대해서는 충분해요.
이제 양자 정보와 여러 시스템에서
어떻게 작동하는지로 관심을 돌릴게요.
패턴은 고전 정보에서와
같아요.
여러 양자 시스템을 단일 복합 시스템으로 볼 수 있고,
이전 수업에서 배운 것을 적용할 수 있어요.
다시, 텐서 곱이 핵심 역할을 할 거예요.
그리고 전반적으로 여러 시스템에 대한 양자 정보가
어떻게 작동하는지에 대한 설명을 얻어요.
고전 정보에 대해 방금 본 것과
매우 유사하고 수학적으로 비슷해요.
양자 상태부터 시작할게요.
여러 시스템의 양자 상태는 복소수 원소를 가지고
유클리드 노름이 1인 열 벡터로 표현돼요.
단일 시스템의 양자 상태와
똑같이요.
이번에는 양자 상태 벡터의 인덱스가 개별 시스템의
고전적 상태 집합의 데카르트 곱에 해당해요.
왜냐하면 그게 복합 시스템의
고전적 상태 집합이기 때문이에요.
예를 들어, X와 Y가 qubit이면, 쌍 XY의 고전적 상태 집합은
이진 알파벳 자신과의 데카르트 곱이에요.
길이가 2인 모든 이진 문자열의
집합으로 생각할 수 있어요.
따라서 여기서 보이는 이 벡터들은 모두
XY의 양자 상태 벡터의 예예요.
원한다면, 각 qubit에 대해 별개의 켓이 있는
이런 벡터들로 대신 쓸 수 있어요.
그것들 사이의 텐서 곱은
암묵적이에요.
또는 원하면 이렇게 텐서 곱 기호를
명시적으로 쓸 수도 있어요.
또 다른 옵션은 켓에 나타내는 시스템의 이름을
이렇게 아래 첨자로 쓰는 거예요.
텐서 곱 기호를 사용하거나
사용하지 않고 이렇게 할 수 있어요.
그게 내용을 명확하게 유지하는 데
매우 도움이 될 때가 있어요.
이것들은 같은 벡터를 표현하는 다양한 스타일이고,
원하는 것이나 선호하는 것 또는 가장 이치에 맞는 것을 선택할 수 있어요.
현재 상황에 맞는 것으로요. 예를 들어 상황이 더 복잡해지면,
이 스타일 중 하나가 명확성을 더한다고 판단할 수 있어요.
그리고 원하는 선택을 자유롭게
할 수 있어요.
양자 상태 벡터의 텐서 곱도
양자 상태 벡터예요.
예를 들어 두 시스템의 경우, Phi가 시스템 X의 양자 상태 벡터이고
Psi가 시스템 Y의 양자 상태 벡터이면,
Phi와 Psi의 텐서 곱이
XY의 양자 상태 벡터예요.
이런 상태를 곱 상태라고 하고, 고전 확률적 환경에서 본 것과 유사하게
시스템 X와 Y 사이의 독립성을 나타내요.
예를 들어, 어떤 사람이 세계 한 곳에 실험실이 있고
시스템 X를 만들어서 양자 상태 Phi로 초기화하면,
세계 다른 곳의 또 다른 사람이 독립적으로
시스템 Y를 양자 상태 Psi로 초기화하면,
세계의 다른 부분에 있더라도 XY를 단일 시스템으로 생각하기로 선택하면,
복합 시스템 XY는
Phi 텐서 Psi 상태에 있어요.
이 모든 것은 자연스러운 방식으로
두 개 이상의 시스템으로 일반화돼요.
별개의 시스템 X1부터 Xn의 양자 상태 Psi1부터 PsiN이 있으면,
이 n개의 벡터들의 텐서 곱은
양자 상태를 나타내고, 이것도 복합 시스템 X1부터 Xn의 곱 상태라고 해요.
두 qubit의 양자 상태
예가 있어요.
처음에는 그렇게 보이지 않을 수도 있지만, 이건 곱 상태의 예예요.
여기서 보이는 것처럼 텐서 곱으로 쓸 수 있기 때문이에요.
따라서 어떻게 쓰든 곱 상태의 예예요.
관련 있는 건 텐서 곱으로 쓸 수 있는지 여부예요.
하지만 이 양자 상태는, 역시 두 qubit의 상태인데,
곱 상태가 아니에요.
두 개의 완전히 상관된 무작위 비트의 확률적 환경에서 본 예와
정신적으로 비슷해요.
그리고 같은 논증으로 텐서 곱으로 쓸 수 없다는 게
드러나요.
이걸 여기로 옮기고 논증을 좀 더 자세히 살펴볼게요.
이 상태를 두 벡터 Phi와 Psi의
텐서 곱으로 쓸 수 있다고 상상해 봐요.
고전적 상태 0,1에 해당하는 원소는
이 벡터에서 0이에요. 그냥 봐도 알 수 있어요.
하지만 그 벡터가 두 벡터의 텐서 곱이라면,
Phi의 0 원소 곱하기 Psi의 1 원소가
0과 같을 거예요. 하지만 그건 Phi의 0 원소나
Psi의 1 원소가 0과 같다는 의미예요.
또는 둘 다 0일 수도 있지만, 그건 여기 이 두 곱이 모두
0이 아니어야 한다는 사실에 모순돼요.
그것들은 루트 2분의 1과 같아요. 논증은 실제로
확률적 환경에서의 것과 거의 동일해요.
이것에 대해 특별히 양자적인 것은
전혀 없어요.
어쨌든, 원래 상태가 곱 상태가
아니라는 걸 알게 돼요.
여기 이 두 숫자가 루트 2분의 1이라는 건
중요하지 않아요.
중요한 건 두 값이
모두 0이 아니라는 거예요.
이 특정 양자 상태는 매우 흥미로워요.
두 qubit의 얽힌 상태의 예예요.
얽힘에 대해서는
나중에 더 이야기할 거예요.
얽힘은 복잡할 수 있어요. 특히 양자 정보의
일반적인 공식화에서 양자 상태를 이야기할 때요.
하지만 여기 단순화된 양자 정보 설명에서 얽힘은
독립성의 결여와 동치예요.
따라서 양자 상태 벡터의 경우, 곱 상태가 아니면
얽힌 상태이고, 이 특정 상태는
일반적으로 얽힌 양자 상태의
전형적인 예로 여겨져요.
실제로, 특히 얽힘을 흥미로운 일을 할 수 있는 자원으로
생각할 때, 이 상태를 얽힘의 한 단위로
나타내는 것으로 생각할 때가 있어요.
사용될 수 있는 자원으로요.
방금 이야기한 양자 상태는 네 개의 소위 벨 상태 중 하나예요.
여기서 이름과 함께 볼 수 있어요.
이 상태들에 일반적으로 사용되는 이름들이에요.
Phi 플러스, Phi 마이너스, Psi 플러스, Psi 마이너스예요.
모두 얽혀 있고, 두 qubit의 상태를 나타내는 모든 벡터의
공간에 대한 기저를 형성해요.
따라서 이 네 개의 벡터를 합쳐서
벨 기저라고 해요.
매우 흔히 접하는 양자 상태 모음이에요.
1960년대에 얽힘 연구에 매우 중요한
기여를 한 물리학자
John Bell의 이름을 따서 명명됐어요.
세 qubit의 양자 상태의 잘 알려진
예 두 가지가 있어요.
첫 번째는 GHZ 상태라고 해요.
방금 본 Phi 플러스 상태와 비슷한데,
두 qubit 대신 세 qubit에 대한 거예요.
두 번째 예는 W 상태라고 하고 여기서 보이는 것처럼 생겼어요.
세 개의 이진 문자열에 대해 균일해요.
길이가 3이고 정확히 하나의 비트가
1로 설정된 문자열들이에요.
이 상태들 중 어느 것도 곱 상태가 아니고, 둘 다 흥미로운 성질을 가지며
예로 꽤 흔히 나타나요. 알아두면 좋고, 다시 보게 될 거예요.
다음으로 양자 상태에서 시스템의
측정에 대해 이야기할게요.
수업에서 지금까지 따라온 같은 추론을 따라서요.
여러 시스템을 단일 시스템인 것처럼 생각하는 거예요.
단일 시스템인 것처럼요. 모든 시스템이 측정될 경우에, 여러 양자 시스템의 측정이
어떻게 작동하는지에 대한 설명에 즉시 도달해요.
모든 시스템이
측정되는 경우요.
즉, n-튜플 시스템의 양자 상태를 나타내는
어떤 양자 상태 벡터 Psi가 있고,
X1부터 Xn까지이고 전체 복합 시스템을 측정하면,
그건 모든 개별 시스템을 측정하는 것과 동치예요.
그러면 고전적 상태의 각 가능한 n-튜플이
측정의 결과가 될 거예요.
그 n-튜플에 해당하는 Psi의 원소의 절댓값의
제곱과 같은 확률로요.
예를 들어, 여기 이 양자 상태에 있는 시스템 쌍 XY가 있으면,
두 시스템을 모두 측정하면,
X의 측정에서 0, Y의 측정에서 하트를 의미하는
결과 0 하트를 얻어요.
9/25의 확률로요. 그리고 16/25의 확률로
결과 1 스페이드를 얻어요.
꽤 간단해요. 본질적으로 두 개의 별개 시스템이라는 사실을 무시하고
하나의 단일 시스템인 것처럼 보는 거예요.
하지만 이것은 다음과 같은 자연스러운 질문을 제기해요.
고전적 환경에서 이미 고려했던 질문이에요.
두 시스템 X와 Y가 집합적으로 어떤 양자 상태에 있는데,
둘 다 측정하지 않고 하나의 시스템만 측정한다고 가정해요.
시스템 X를 측정하고 Y는
아무것도 하지 않는다고 해요.
물론, Y를 측정하고 X는 하지 않으면 어떻게 되는지,
더 일반적으로 세 개 이상의 시스템이 있을 때
어떻게 되는지 물을 수도 있어요.
그 적절한 부분집합을 측정하는 경우요. 하지만 이 질문에 대한 답을 얻으면,
그 질문들에 대한 답도 얻게 돼요.
일반적으로 쌍 XY의 양자 상태 벡터는
여기서 보이는 형태를 취한다는 걸 알아요.
sigma와 gamma가 각각
X와 Y의 고전적 상태 집합이라고
평소처럼 가정하면서요.
이 벡터의 원소는 a와 b의 모든 가능한 선택에 걸쳐
alpha ab로 표시돼요.
그리고 이 벡터를 단위 벡터로 만드는 임의의
복소수일 수 있어요.
이제 두 시스템 모두 측정되면, 다양한 가능한 결과에 대한 확률을
얻는다는 걸 이미 알아요.
해당 원소의 절댓값의 제곱을 취해서요.
X만 측정되면, 특정 결과 a를 얻을 확률은
이 식으로 주어져요.
Y도 측정됐을 때 얻을 수 있는 모든 가능한 결과 b에 대해
단순히 합을 취해요. 실제로는 측정하지 않더라도요.
아이디어는 확률적 환경에서와
같아요.
X가 측정될 때 특정 결과를 얻을 확률은
Y도 측정되었는지 여부에 달라질 수 없어요.
따라서 다양한 가능한 결과에 대한 확률이
무엇인지 알 수 있어요.
또한, X에 이 측정을 수행하고 특정 결과를 얻은 결과로
Y의 상태에 어떤 변화가 있을 거예요.
이게 어떻게 작동하는지
살펴볼게요.
확률적 환경에서 했던 것과 유사하게, 양자 상태 벡터 Psi를
여기서 보이는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
Phi a는 시스템 X의 고전적 상태 a의 각 선택에 대한
이 벡터예요.
이전처럼 텐서 곱의
이중선형성을 사용해요.
이번에는 편의를 위해 이 다른 벡터들에
Phi a라는 이름을 붙이기로 했어요.
측정이 각 가능한 결과 a를 낼 확률이
여기서 보이는 것과 같다는 걸 이미 관찰했어요.
하지만 이제 이 확률이 벡터 Phi a의
유클리드 노름의 제곱과 같다는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
그리고 이제 X의 측정이 특정 결과 a를 줌에 따라,
복합 시스템 XY의 양자 상태는
여기서 보이는 이 상태가
돼요.
단일 시스템에서 했던 것처럼, 상태는 본질적으로 붕괴하지만,
일반적으로 완전히 붕괴하지는 않아요.
X의 측정이 결과 a를 낸 것과 일치하는 데
필요한 만큼만 붕괴해요.
Y의 양자 상태는 정규화된 Phi a가 돼요.
즉, 유클리드 노름으로 나눠요.
단위 벡터가 되도록요. 이건 확률적 환경에서 일어난 것과 유사해요.
유클리드 노름으로 나누는 대신,
확률 벡터를 얻기 위해
Phi a의 원소들의 합으로 나눴어요.
하지만 여기서는 양자 상태에 대해 이야기하기 때문에,
양자 상태 벡터를 얻기 위해 유클리드 노름으로 나눠요.
특정 상태에서 어떻게 작동하는지 보기 위해
몇 가지 예를 살펴볼게요.
여기 고려할 상태가 있어요. X와 Y가 qubit이고
이 특정 상태 Psi에 있다고 가정해요.
X가 측정된다고 가정해요.
여기서 보이는 것처럼 상태 Psi를 써서 시작해요.
X의 표준 기저 인수를 효과적으로 분리하고
원래 상태를 얻기 위해 필요한 것과
텐서 곱을 취해요.
방금 전의 일반적인 설명에서와
똑같이요.
결과 0을 얻을 확률은 여기 이 벡터의
유클리드 노름의 제곱이에요.
벡터 Psi의 표현에서 |0>에 텐서 곱된 것이에요.
따라서 확률은 3/4이고,
결과 0을 얻는 것에 조건부로요.
쌍 XY의 양자 상태는 이것이 돼요.
|0>에 텐서 곱된 벡터를 정규화하는 거예요.
그리고 이건 방금 계산한 확률의
제곱근으로 나누는 것과 동치예요.
그러면 단순화할 수 있고,
이 결과를 얻어요.
측정 결과 1을 얻을 확률은
비슷한 방식으로 계산돼요.
여기 이 벡터의 유클리드 노름의 제곱을 취해요.
Psi의 표현에서 |1>에 텐서 곱된 것이에요.
결과 확률은 1/4이에요.
물론 확률의 합이 1이 되어야 하므로 그래야 해요.
이 경우, XY의 양자 상태는 이것이 돼요.
유클리드 노름으로 나눠서 정규화해요.
그래서 이 양자 상태 벡터를
결과로 얻어요.
X 대신 Y가 측정되면,
같은 방법을 대칭적으로 사용해요.
원래 양자 상태 벡터가 있고, X 대신 Y가
측정되기 때문에,
벡터 Psi를 여기서 보이는 것처럼 표현해요.
이번에는 X 대신 Y의 표준 기저 벡터를 분리해요.
X 대신 Y를, Psi의 표현을 얻기 위해 필요한 것과
텐서 곱을 취하면서요.
원하면 영상을 일시 정지해서 확인할 수 있는
계산을 해 보면,
이번에 결과 0을 얻을 확률은 5/8이고,
여기 양자 상태 벡터가 있어요.
그 결과를 얻는 것에 조건부로
나오는 양자 상태 벡터예요.
결과 1을 얻을 확률은 3/8이고,
이 경우 이게 우리의 양자 상태 벡터예요.
두 개 이상의 시스템이 있고 그 적절한 부분집합이 측정되는 경우에도
정확히 같은 방법을 사용할 수 있어요.
그리고 관심이 있으면 확인할 수 있는 이 수업의
교재 내용에 예가 있어요.
간단히 말해서, 시스템을 항상 두 개의 별개 모음으로 나눌 수 있어요.
측정되는 것들과 그렇지 않은 것들로요.
그렇게 하면, 방금 설명한 방법으로 돌아가요.
그게 여러 양자 시스템의 측정이 작동하는 방식이에요.
이제 마지막으로, 여러 시스템에 대한
유니터리 연산으로 넘어가요.
여러 시스템을 단일 복합 시스템으로 볼 수 있다는
같은 기본 아이디어를 사용해서요.
화면에 쓰인 것을 결론 내려요.
복합 시스템에 대한 양자 연산은 유니터리 행렬로 표현돼요.
단일 시스템에서와 마찬가지로요. 구체적으로 그 유니터리 행렬들의
행과 열은 데카르트 곱에 해당해요.
우리가 이야기하는 시스템 모음의
고전적 상태 집합들의 데카르트 곱이요.
예를 들어, 고전적 상태가 1, 2, 3인 시스템 X가 있고
Y가 qubit이면,
여기서 보이는 행렬은 쌍 XY에 대한 연산을 나타내는
유니터리 행렬의 예예요.
앞서 이야기한 데카르트 곱을 정렬하는 방법의 세부 사항은
이 예를 위해서는 크게 중요하지 않아요.
그냥 유니터리인 6x6 행렬이에요.
특별한 게 없지만, 몇 가지 중요한 행렬로
만들어져 있어요.
핵심은 임의의 6x6 유니터리 행렬을 선택할 수 있고
그것이 XY에 대한 유니터리 연산을 나타낼 수 있다는 거예요.
각각 자신의 시스템에서 독립적으로 유니터리 연산 모음을 적용하면,
모두 함께하는 그것들의 작용은
복합 시스템에서 텐서 곱으로
주어져요.
그리고 화면에서 그 사실의 더 정확한
표현을 볼 수 있어요.
유니터리 연산들이 각 시스템에 하나씩
유니터리 행렬 U1부터 Un으로 설명되면,
복합 시스템에 대한 결합 작용은
U1부터 Un까지의 텐서 곱으로 주어져요.
다시, 확률적 환경에서와 유사하게, 중요한 예는
어떤 유니터리 연산을 적용하는 거예요.
시스템 X에 U를 적용하고
다른 시스템 Y에는 아무것도 하지 않는 거예요.
XY에 대해 얻는 연산은 U와 항등 행렬의
텐서 곱이에요.
항등 행렬은
Y에 아무것도 하지 않는 것을 설명해요.
이 항등 행렬이 시스템 Y에 해당한다는 걸 명시적으로 쓰는 게
공식을 더 명확하게 하기 위해 때때로 도움이 돼요.
한 가지 옵션은 항등 행렬에 이렇게 아래 첨자를 붙여서
작용하는 시스템을 나타내는 거예요.
하지만 충분히 명확할 때는 보통 아래 첨자를 신경 쓰지 않아요.
상황이 더 복잡해지면 매우 도움이 될 수 있지만요.
Y에 유니터리 연산 V가 적용되고
X에는 아무것도 하지 않는 대칭적인 경우도 고려할 수 있어요.
이번에는 XY에 대한 결과 유니터리 연산이
여기 이 텐서 곱으로 표현돼요.
그리고 다시, 도움이 되면 항등 행렬에
아래 첨자를 붙일 수 있어요.
몇 가지 구체적인 예가 있어요.
X와 Y가 qubit이고 X에 Hadamard 연산을 수행하고
Y에는 아무것도 하지 않으면, 여기서 보이는 행렬을 얻어요.
반면에 Y에 Hadamard 연산을 수행하고 X에는 아무것도 하지 않으면,
텐서 곱의 순서가 반대가 돼요.
그래서 여기서 보이는
행렬을 얻어요.
복합 시스템의 모든 유니터리 연산을
텐서 곱으로 표현할 수 있는 건 아니에요.
텐서 곱이 있으면
독립성이 있어요.
여러 시스템에서 독립적으로 작용하지 않는
연산들의 꽤 근본적인 예들이 있어요.
예를 들어, X와 Y가 같은 고전적 상태 집합을 가지면,
그게 임의의 고전적 상태 집합 sigma일 수 있는데,
쌍 XY에 대한 스왑 연산을
생각할 수 있어요.
이 연산은 두 시스템의 순서를 바꾸지 않아요.
여전히 왼쪽에 X, 오른쪽에 Y가 있어요.
하지만 두 시스템의 내용을 바꾸는 것을 나타내요.
두 시스템의 내용을요. 여기서 두 양자 상태의
텐서 곱이 있는 방정식 형태로 표현된 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이것을 행렬로 쓰는 또 다른 방법은
여기서 보이는 것처럼이에요.
이 설명에 대해 생각할 수 있는 방법은
표준 기저 벡터에 어떤 일이 일어나는지 알려준다는 거예요.
그리고 표준 기저 벡터에 어떤 일이 일어나는지 알면,
선형성에 의해 임의의 양자 상태에 어떤 일이 일어나는지 알아요.
사실 여기 이 식에 대해서도 참이에요.
따라서 여기 이 특정 연산은 유니터리 연산이기도 하고
결정론적 연산이기도 해요.
예를 들어 X와 Y가 qubit이면, 여기 이 행렬 표현을
얻어요.
스왑 연산과 네 개의 벨 상태 사이에
흥미로운 연결이 있어요. 여기 편의를 위해 보여줘요.
스왑 연산은 처음 세 개를 그대로 두지만,
Psi 마이너스 상태 앞에 마이너스 부호를 붙여요.
그래서 그것에는 특별한 무언가가
있어요.
이 방정식들을 직접 확인하려면 이 벡터들을 보고
표준 기저 상태에 어떤 일이 일어나는지 고려해 봐요.
처음 세 개의 벨 상태에 대해 두 고전적 상태를 바꿔도
아무것도 바뀌지 않고 시작했던 것과 같은 상태를 얻어요.
하지만 네 번째 경우, 고전적 상태의 스왑을 수행할 때
마이너스 부호가 한 항에서 다른 항으로 효과적으로 이동해요.
그리고 이건 벡터에 마이너스 1을 곱하는 것과
동치예요.
따라서 스왑 연산을 수행하면 이 네 번째 벨 상태에서
마이너스 부호가 나오게 돼요.
이 방정식들에 대해서는 나중에 더 이야기할 거예요.
이제 또 다른 유형의 연산인 제어 연산으로 넘어가요.
X가 qubit이고 Y는 원하는 임의의 시스템이라고 가정해요.
U가 Y에 대한 유니터리 연산이면, XY에 대한 제어 U 연산은
여기서 표현된 연산이에요.
먼저 직접 표기법을 사용하고, 그런 다음 블록 행렬이라고 하는 것을 사용해요.
이 더 큰 행렬에 더 작은 것들을 채워 넣는다고 상상해요.
이 0들은 실제로 0으로 채워진 행렬을 나타내요.
따라서 이 네 블록 각각은 Y의 고전적 상태 수와 일치하는
행과 열 수를 가진 행렬을 나타내요.
제어 연산의 아이디어는, 고전 환경에서 controlled-NOT 연산을
논의할 때 이미 봤는데,
X가 0으로 설정되면
Y에는 아무것도 일어나지 않아요.
하지만 X가 1로 설정되면
U가 Y에 적용돼요.
따라서 X는 제어 qubit이라고 하고, Y는 목표 시스템이라고 해요.
일반적으로 qubit일 필요는 없어요.
방금 언급한 구체적인 예로,
controlled-NOT 연산이 있어요.
첫 번째 qubit이 0으로 설정되면 아무것도 일어나지 않아요.
첫 번째 qubit이 1로 설정되면 NOT 연산이, 동치로는
시그마 X 연산이 두 번째 qubit에
적용돼요.
그리고 여기 행렬 표현이 있어요.
여기서 두 qubit에 대해 이야기하고 있으므로, 두 번째 qubit을 제어로
첫 번째를 목표로 결정할 수도 있어요.
그 연산을 설명하려면 텐서 곱의 순서를 바꾸면 되고,
결과는 여기서 보이는 행렬이에요.
controlled-NOT 연산 대신 제어 시그마 Z 또는
controlled Z 연산을 고려하면,
여기 이 행렬 표현을 얻어요. 이 경우 어느 쪽이 제어이고
어느 쪽이 목표인지는 실제로 중요하지 않아요.
어느 쪽이든 같은 결과를
얻어요.
더 나아가 제어 스왑 연산을
고려할 수 있어요.
여기서 두 qubit을 스왑하는 것에 대해 이야기하므로,
제어 qubit을 포함하면 세 qubit이 돼요.
각 행렬 표현은
이렇게 생겼어요.
꽤 특별한 연산이고 Fredkin 연산 또는 더 흔히
Fredkin gate라고 알려져 있어요.
circuit에서 gate로 생각할 때, circuit에 대해서는
다음 수업에서 다룰 거예요.
마지막 예는 controlled controlled-NOT 연산으로,
다시 세 qubit에 대한 연산이에요.
그리고 여기 행렬 표현이 있어요. 이 연산은 Toffoli 연산 또는
Toffoli gate로 훨씬 더 잘 알려져 있어요.
나중 수업에서 더 자세히 논의하고 Fredkin과 Toffoli가
왜 매우 중요한 연산인지 알 거예요.
이제 두 번째 수업이 끝났어요. 이번 수업에서 여러 시스템에 대해
양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 논의했어요.
곧 세 번째 수업에서 함께하길 바라요.
양자 circuit, 프로토콜, 게임에 관한 수업이에요.
그때까지 안녕히 계세요.